Maps, everybody uses them and
many people love them.
Maps on mobile devices like this one
have changed the world over the last
few years.
It's not that long ago you had to carry
a paper map of any location you weren't
familiar with.
Or like me, as soon as you arrive at
an airport, you'd study the route to
the hotel, memorizing it so you wouldn't
have to stop in a strange place and
unfold a large piece of paper to
figure out where you were going.
Mobile maps not only provide
a local map in your pocket, but
also a map of the entire
world down to street level.
They also include cool things such as a
view of the street as if you were there
or a 3D fly-around of many major cities.
There are so many ways that maps
can help you build a better app.
Maybe you have a business and you want
to direct people to that business.
Why not build an app that provides
navigation to your business from where
they are using location services that
you can learn in one of our modules?
Or maybe you want to create a treasure
hunt game, or plant a geocache.
You can even do this virtually,
where instead of hiding objects in the
real world, you put them in the virtual
world, with pins on a map that
your users will then have to find.
There are far more scenarios
than I can think of and
I bet you have a few
doozies of your own.
In this lesson,
you'll learn all about Google Maps and
how you can build them
into your android apps.